all right so Jesse the this would not be
unprecedented but Kevin McCarthy is
talking about in terms of taking members
off committee that was what the
Democrats did last year to a couple of
Republicans there's a walnut sized area
that's nestled right here in the frontal
part of people's brain it's called
something cortex I'm not really sure
what it is but it's there for planning
ahead and it what makes human beings
unique and I believe if scientists
cracked open the brains of Democrats
they wouldn't find anything there
because they have a childlike inability
to plan ahead who would have thought
that the Republicans would come back and
do the exact same things the Democrats
did to them it's like they never
imagined a scenario where they would
lose power and they only did this
because Kevin McCarthy doesn't want to
do this he has to do this because when
your opponent drops a weapon in order to
survive you pick that weapon up and then
you attack your opponent with that
weapon
let's go through these people swallow so
he fell for a Chinese Communist Honey
Trap so he's either compromised or too
stupid to be on the intelligence
committee and then there's Adam Schiff
who totally discredited the intelligence
committee because he would go into these
briefings he'd hear that there was no
collusion and that he'd speed out of the
briefings and leak to the press that
there was collusion and he was involved
in orchestrating that stupid
whistleblower to come out and spill the
beans on the perfect phone call just to
try to disguise the fact that Joe's
family was corrupt in Ukraine and he
fell for a prank phone call and tried to
get pictures of Donald Trump in his
underwear so he's either a pervert or
too stupid again to be on the
intelligence committee now Omar I don't
really know what she said but it seems
like she's the Kanye West of Foreign
Affairs so if the Democrats want to
boycott Kanye they have to boycott her
in order to be consistent but either way
the Democrats had this coming even the
Democrats thought about censoring Omar
but didn't I thought that one thing
Kevin McCarthy was said was very
interesting about Eric swalwell that he
couldn't get a security clearance in the
private sector so why should he be
allowed one in Congress I don't think he
could get a security clearance at a Cub
Scout Treehouse I mean it's true what
Jesse said he was honey potted by a
Chinese spy this is like exactly what
corporate videos tell people when
they're traveling your warning don't get
compromised beware of a really
attractive woman hitting on you it is
not because of how you look it's like
they would show up in the in the video
they would show a picture of Eric
swalwell you do not attract beautiful
women at bars and you should that should
tip you off immediately that no it's not
your lucky day right and that's where
ilhan Omar she will not be on the
Foreign Affairs but what about family
Affairs no ladies and gentlemen did you
see that one coming up but I think um
the first up I think that would
Republicans could do don't take any
advice from anyone in the media about
proposed hearings because they play for
the other side that's their game they're
going to say that you know we have so
many things to concentrate on this is
going to distract us with from the
bigger problems as if they you know they
really were on top of covid during
impeachment so you got those three
things you know majorca's the whip gate
51 Intel agents we should every day we
should meet a new Intel agent that
signed that letter that said that Hunter
Biden laptop was residence info and um
the origins of kovid which I think we
can all agree you know but when the
media says it's a waste of time that
means it's worth it the other thing is
is that remember when the whole
Clinton's Monica Lewinsky scandal
happened back back then the Democrats
created moveon.org there's a lot of
money to try to defend against us well
they've done it again and Arabella
Network it was basically like liberal
money coming in to basically fund they
already have 1.5 million dollars and
they're mainly trying to do PR right now
to talk to the media to try to get them
set up judge well yeah I mean they
understand that it takes money they know
how to collect money they don't care
whether it's dark money or where it's
from they're going to do it to defend
themselves and you know the crazy part
about all this is that it's the
Democrats I mean it was it was uh uh
Obama who said elections have
consequences I mean we could say the
same thing to them elections have
consequences so your people are going to
go no one better than ill had Omar and
by the way for all of the things that
she said about Israel and her
anti-semitic tropes and everything else
she wasn't thrown off any committees
they kept her on Foreign Affairs Nancy
Pelosi said it was fine and then they
passed this resolution and they never
even put name in it they just said you
know we we object to hate speech and
they let her they let her off the hook
it was crazy and so they removed
Marjorie Taylor green so I would expect
that they would at the very least remove
Adam Schiff and I'll tell you why he's a
former prosecutor he's a lawyer he comes
out and he swears he says I have
evidence Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
Beyond a reasonable doubt that that
Donald Trump colluded with the Russians
every day he came out and said it and he
lied to the American people and he
contributed to the divide in this
country which we didn't need and when it
came time to say it under oath he
admitted he had nothing so in the end
what we've got here is we have a whole
group that's got to go from ilhan Omar
to him and to swalwell swallows you know
is he's a liar and you know he got
caught by Honeypot go ahead Jessica I
don't know if Eric swalwell is a liar
U.S officials that investigated after I
came to light that he was seeing a woman
who was a Chinese spy they've said that
it doesn't appear that she got any
classified information he hasn't been in
contact with her since 2015 and she's
like get that from U.S officials
the same ones that said they were
Russian collusions
let's give her a chance to talk that
Walnut thing in the front of my brain is
short-circuiting so I don't know if I
can get through my talking points but
I've been very critical of Elan Omar the
you know it's all about the Benjamins
the Dual loyalty stuff um I wish that
there was no place in the Democratic
party for that kind of thinking and that
kind of speech um but I appreciate that
the judge actually said Marjorie Taylor
Green's name out loud because everyone
else said you know this is what the
Democrats did Marjorie Taylor green
beyond the Jewish space lasers that
started wildfires in California the
reason that she was really taken off the
committee is because she liked a post
that was about putting bullets in the
heads of other Democrats and there were
a number of Republicans who supported
her pulling off of committees because if
you want your opponent to die you do not
have any place serving on these
commissions as far as no don't say that
it cannot be eye for an eye if the eyes
are not comparable at all and they
aren't in this case Eric swallow I I get
the security clearance argument let's
see what happens there but for the rest
of it it makes absolutely no sense to me
you know the thing is what you're saying
is our bad guy is not as bad as your bad
guy and that's bias because we could say
the same thing our bad it's it's I think
our bad our good guys are better than
your good guys our bad girls better than
that girl exactly yeah
Jessica we both both we both sides have
bad girls we should send both bad girls
to their room until they learn a lesson